well the san francisco 49ers took more
than a month to make their decision
with what they would do with the third
overall pick in the draft after making
the big trade to get it and it became
north dakota state's trey lance not mac
jones the guy that many thought it would
be a guy who's more
game ready instead lance a guy who only
played one game
last year a guy who's a bit of a project
does that mean
they're more likely to keep jimmy
garoppolo around for another year or
will they throw
trey lance into the fray there had been
reporting
that some in the front office really
wanted trey lance it was believed mac
jones was coach kyle shanahan's guy
if so shanahan ultimately yielding to
others and going with the guy that they
decided
after taking that time and doing their
due diligence and
showing up at the dealership intending
to buy a ferrari in mack jones they go
with the
high-end performance porsche instead
in trey lance now we'll see where mac
jones ends up and also
how far to justin fields the other guy
the 49ers could have taken
fall down the draft board and finally
what does this mean
and what will they do with jimmy
garoppolo all things to be determined
over the course of tonight
and possibly beyond hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports